No,
I don't,
I,
my grandmother was a terrible cook,
uh,
and,
and my mother died when I was very young
and my father was a terrible cook,
so I think,
you know,
uh,
they,
I overcompensate a little bit like for
the cooking end of things.
So I don't know why,
I don't know what drove me to,
to be a chef exactly.
But the kind of chef that I've become,
I think was,
you know,
sort of unconsciously inculcated by this
connection to the land,
especially to like my grandma's sense of
responsibility,
which was huge.
It was like,
it was like she,
she very much believed in open space
and,
and in doing everything possible to
preserve it.
And that meant farming in the case of
where Blue Hill wasn't meant to preserve
that the pastoral,
you literally needed to pasture.
Uh,
and so,
you know,
there was a responsibility came attached
to the pleasure of the views literally.
Um,
and I think somehow I have connected
that with food and the idea that,
you know,
have those views and that open space,
you've got to eat it.
Uh,
so,
you know,
it's,
it's chef and it's,
you know,
it's being a chef and,
and providing pleasure by way of a kind
of responsibility that's um,
yes,
that's pleasurable in and of itself.
I graduated and I was a little bit lost
on what to do and I went out and I baked
bread in California for awhile and kind
of cooked on the side,
just starting some money and I thought
actually maybe I'd write about,
I was going to write about a bunch of
things,
but I ended up just earning extra money
by cooking and that led one thing led to
another and I,
you know,
I was always kind of undecided until I
think I went to France and then I was
really cooking and that was sort of a
light went off I think,
although it was an Aha moment,
you know,
it wasn't one of those things I just
like,
I'm still questioning as we sit here
now.
Yeah.